marc y además gracias por estar con
nosotros y para ustedes cuál es la
importancia de estas resoluciones de la
asamblea de general contra la invasión
rusa pese a que no es una resolución
vinculante
pues evidentemente lo que usted dice el
final angela no es vinculante pero fue
la estrategia la fórmula como la eeuu
logró que lo que no pasaba en el consejo
de seguridad porque había desde esto de
rusia pudiera pasar a través de un
mensaje político es como una sanción
política es como un éxito porque uno
sabe que hay 142 países que
definitivamente apoyan a ucrania de los
193 y sólo 5 votos en contra y los
latinoamericanos que son afines
dijéramos a rusia ciertamente nicaragua
bolivia
venezuela
y por supuesto la habana cuba pues no
votaron en contra sino que se
abstuvieron eso es una gran noticia y
china que es lo más interesante para mí
china definitivamente en esta ronda se
abstuvo como la del consejo de seguridad
o sea que debe estar pensando en un
juego o en una jugada estratégica de
negociador de gran negociador
y rusia y occidente sobre esos países
latinos que mencionaba hace un momento
le quería preguntar es 5 votos en contra
35 abstenciones entre ellos ya lo dije
ustedes bolivia cuba el salvador y
nicaragua por américa latina qué
significa esta decisión de evitar la
condena para nuestra región
pues mire que yo creí de mi experiencia
que iban a votar en contra que se iban a
unir a los votos en contra y no fue así
o sea se abstuvieron que eso ya es algo
no se votaron a esas 35 naciones pero
igual las relaciones de venezuela son
indudablemente muy sólidas y muy
peligrosas para colombia en la medida en
que pues el vicepremier ministro estuvo
borísov estuvo hace tres semanas en
venezuela en caracas en la habana y en
managua visitando los iii y ofreciendo
dijéramos un acuerdo militar cosa que
hoy no se va a dar porque estamos en una
guerra una posible tercera guerra
mundial como el propio ministro de
exteriores de rusia lávrov dijo hoy
mismo que era que íbamos a en la medida
en que ampliaron las sanciones vendrían
a una guerra nuclear que es algo
impensable dijéramos en este 2022 es
todo si es que eeuu decidiera
involucrarse directamente en la guerra
mientras tanto mire algunos países maría
ema y sacar a rusia del consejo
permanente porque cuando ingresó al
grupo lo hizo con el título de unión
soviética usted qué opina es estudiable
en mis cinco años como embajadora de
colombia ante naciones unidas no fue
posible nosotros hacíamos reuniones de
lo que se llama el grupo de todas las
naciones
a favor de una reforma de lo que fue las
naciones unidas- del 45 es que no
existía áfrica por ejemplo no eran
colonias todavía entonces eso no los
cinco miembros no solamente rusia y
china- no también eeuu el reino unido y
francia- no quieren perder ese
privilegio del veto y no van a dejar que
eso cambie como ellos tienen veto pues
por eso nos tocó dice en la asamblea
general por lo menos a una sanción
política como usted decía no vinculante
pero yo lo veo muy difícil pero este es
el momento en que los organismos
multilaterales muestran que así no sirve
sólo la otan y los países de occidente y
el liderazgo del bait en que como que
resucitó después del desastre de
afganistán y ahí está como como
aplaudido ayer en el estado de la unión
por republicanos y demócratas